a study conducted by the University of
Chicago and the University of Munich
revealed that job Seekers with the
southern accent may experience a wage
penalty potentially earning thousands of
dollars less per year the research
indicated that individuals with strong
Regional access particularly Southern
Accents could face a weight penalty of
up to 20 percent compared to those with
standard accent another study conducted
by the writing tips Institute found that
38 of job Seekers admitted to modifying
their accent during an interview due to
negative stereotypes the study
identified the profession with job
applicants are more likely to change
their accents as real estate tourism
Public Service Information Technology
you know science engineering Hospitality
Finance retail health care and media you
sound like a stupid Blaster Tom you
sound like a dumb bastard I'm sorry for
telling you right now there's a lot of
Truth sometimes the truth hurts I you
know so when the South you know I went
to college in Florida State and there's
some there's other people out there I
also went to college my freshman year I
played football at Greensboro North
Carolina I I hung out there there's a
difference between Southern Charm and
southern hospitality D and being a
Southern Belle and there's all that yeah
and then you have Senator John Kennedy
out of Louisiana oh my God he's the
father that guy went to law school UVA
and he sounds like this he goes hey yeah
you're stupid I'm talking to you out
here and it just it's something that dog
don't hunt no no go back not sound
exactly well the last thing look can you
imagine going against surgery open up
surgery and the doctor's like all right
we're gonna open you up get in your rap
ventricle I'm like no dude I'm good yeah
I gotta get the hell out of here I'll go
to New York the most difficult accent to
deal with this vacation oh yeah oh sorry
coach uh I'm gonna get some water for
you
mama said you're the devil yeah I can
understand why those people are
underappreciated but don't you know
don't judge a book by its cover this
guy's actually a sharp Guy funny dude
but now you're no but now what your chip
could do your chip could do in terms of
linguistics and language skills it
erases us
and then you get your neutral accent you
sound a little bit smarter and you get
the job I wouldn't be shouted if that
happened to him he's like from the Bayou
Louisiana but now he's all smart he's a
senator so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign